so six years ago a nascent unborn even
cryptocurrency called zcash was about to
emerge on the scene zcash uses a new
technology a new map really called zero
knowledge proofs that lets you prove
that something is true without revealing
anything about what it is that you're
proving including not only the thing
itself but your identity this is great
for cryptocurrency because it means that
not only can you shield the values that
are being sent but you don't need to
reveal even a public key
so it's perfect true privacy ironically
in order to pull this off you have to
actually rely on human beings to do a
very elaborate process known as the
creation ceremony zcash recruited six
people from around the world each of
which participated by doing an elaborate
series
of steps that resulted in them briefly
owning
part of what's called the creation key
all six of these pieces of the key if
they were ever united would give the
owner the ability to create infinite
anonymous cryptocurrency but if only one
of these people
destroyed their part of the private
creation key that meant the ceremony had
succeeded these zero knowledge proofs
could be enacted and no one could copy
the cryptocurrency we learned the first
five identities of those people almost
immediately after the ceremony was
revealed but
the sixth person's identity was a
pseudonym john doberton we now know that
john doberton was edward snowden and he
participated uh with an agreement with
zuko wilcox the ceo of the zcash company
that created zcash to protect his
privacy until he felt safe revealing it
we
now have been able to put together a lot
of the backstory about edward snowden's
involvement what i think is most
interesting is snowden didn't just
follow orders right like everybody had
to follow a certain series of
requirements like you had to use it you
had to buy a new computer that no one
had ever used before
it had to have never been connected to
the internet so that no one online
knew anything about the computer
it was snowden himself that actually
made a crucial recommendation that ended
up being followed by every participant
basically that you have to buy this
hardware from a location that not even
you knew existed until you bought it so
like for example if you needed a
computer you had to just drive around
randomly
until you found a place that sold
computers and you had to go in and buy
that computer we were literally three
minutes before you didn't even know you
were going to be doing that this is a
tactic that azuco says the cia employs
to ensure perfect privacy and security
this is something that zcash followed at
the advice of edward snowden the last
thing i should say to be totally clear i
did not interview edward snowden for
this story i approached him and
conversed with a couple of his
representatives the video is our sole
source but i was able to interview zuko
wilcox and got some really fun little
anecdotes about the process notably
counterintuitively you know you think of
the proverbial disguise this is the
glasses with the big nose and the
mustache you know you can put on to
cover your face nodon actually did the
opposite of that because he's so known
for his glasses
that when he wanted to hide his identity
he actually took his glasses off
and apparently when um snowden walks
around moscow
if he has his glasses on um everybody
recognizes him but if he takes his
glasses off no one knows who he is
zcash is now valued at over two billion
dollars the privacy coin space is now an
11 billion dollar space according to
data from coin market cap and we're
seeing as a number of regulations go in
place that look to force uh disclosures
about personal identity and increasing
interest in this privacy coin space
you